what i realized there was that there are
particular modes of existing that we get
in our early 20s many of which are kind
of the lowest common denominator um
limbic hijack route to success that we
can find right like quite a base
transactional transient route to success
as you grow up a little bit more you
realize hang on perhaps this isn't
serving me quite in as much of a
holistic broad view as i want that's
what i saw with fitness what i think you
see with specifically guys maybe with
girls as well the mano pause is someone
realizing that as you get toward the end
of your 20s the values that you had when
you were younger aren't serving you
hello and welcome to deep dive the
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophies strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning in this week's episode of
deep dive i sit down for a chat with my
friend chris williamson chris is a club
promoter tedx speaker youtuber and
podcaster his podcast modern wisdom
shares life lessons from the smartest
people on the planet including the likes
of jordan peterson ryan holliday and
james clear and was born out of chris's
curiosity for self-discovery and after
his existential crisis after appearing
on the tv show love island while i was
on love island i got to observe people
that were that person the pinnacle party
boy right because i was playing this
role i thought i was but it kind of
turned out that i wasn't really and i
had this fatal dose of contrast as i
lived in a villa with no distractions
for four weeks watching these people and
being with them but really still feeling
on the outside in our conversation me
and chris discuss how he shed the party
boy persona in favor of intellect and
meaning before discussing topics like
masculinity role models and the dating
market almost two-thirds of women say
that they would not be in a relationship
with a man who is less educated less
wealthy and lowering status than them so
please feel free to grab a cup of tea
and enjoy the conversation chris welcome
to welcome to the podcast how are you
doing my pleasure man thanks for having
me so we've spoken a few times uh i
think i was on your podcast maybe a year
or two ago so a year ago maybe i think
yeah and then we kind of kept in touch
ever since but one thing i didn't
realize uh when we were doing research
for this i i just did not know anything
about your former life as a professional
party boy yeah and i saw that that's
that's like the third thing on your
twitter you've got youtuber podcaster
and professor former
professional party boy yeah and i feel
like you and i have a few things in
common on the youtuber and podcaster
front but i know literally nothing about
the world of a professional lad okay and
i wonder if you can like are you a
professional lad ali i could have sworn
i want i wanted to be a professional ad
which is why i ended up making youtube
videos about productivity but it kind of
kind of took me a different direction
what was what was your life growing up
and like what was the kind of
professional party boy stuff that you
used to do back in the day like
pre-2015. cool so i'm a club promoter by
trade i still own one of the biggest
events companies in the uk called voodoo
events i've run about a thousand
nightclubs events in my entire life i've
seen a million people go in and out of
them so i've met about a million people
in my life stood on the front door of
nightclubs between 10 p.m and three in
the morning which is a fascinating
insight into human nature because when
people are their inhibitions have gone
and they've had a little bit to drink
it's a pretty interesting petri dish for
things to occur uh and that happened at
uni so i was skinned at uni i started
flying and i was like the best flyer
then i was the best halls flyer then i
was the best junior event manager and i
picked up a franchise when i was 19.
that was called carnage which was a
t-shirt bark roll okay anyone who's
probably 30 or older will remember it
you wore a t-shirt you ticked off tasks
on the back as you went around different
bars so we did really well with that and
then i started doing weekly club nights
and then you pick up more club nights
and then you get managers and then you
get guest listers and now we have a bar
in leeds six nights to weekend leads
four nights a week in newcastle we've
got over a thousand staff we have a
shots company that do shock girls and
sorry what
so shock girls girls who go around and
say hot girls so they sell shots okay so
you want a jager bomb but you can't be
bothered to go to the bar yep good
looking girls go around and sell shots
to people that can't be asked to leave
the dance floor yep they charge you a
little bit of a premium we take the
premium um and pay the girls a little
bit of a cut so we have a bunch of
different sort of nightlife related
businesses
and that was the formative years and
that was until 2017
2018 that was
the bulk of what i did so
okay so i think i think this is an
interesting kind of diver sort of
divergence about paths because when i
was at uni and i was like i need to make
money i decided to make websites whereas
when you were at uni and you needed to
make money you decided to so how does
that work do you just like give flyers
to students and like how much
while you're at uni
twice
you are precisely the sort of one no i
need someone who is desperately lonely
and wants to go out on a night out three
or four nights a week with their friends
got it um
it's a very interesting way to look at
marketing because
what you're playing off the back of is
memetic desire
status
and cool okay what makes something cool
is really really difficult to define so
what we try and do is event promoters is
we create brands um for instance wiki
women ibiza is this sort of pastel and
pink flamingos very girly sort of girl
power but it's a bit retro and chic as
well so we came up with paradiso which
is this flamingo
neon sign and that was a friday that we
launched it's all girly girls get pink
shots and there's different types of
music and stuff and we dress the venue
in pink okay that creates a
image to the market yep we put djs on
that at the right we price it correctly
we deal with the venue that's a
sort of appropriate location for this
and then people hopefully come and then
once you've got them you network to them
you get networkers guest listers that go
and say hey you coming out tonight they
build up their networks they make a
commission on the people that come in oh
uh it's a pretty sophisticated when you
look at a nightclub and you go oh it's
just people getting drunk in the room to
music it's like there's a lot going on
behind the scenes okay and so were you
one of the kind of networkers originally
yes okay so you would kind of make
friends with because like on my on my
college's facebook page there would be a
guy
his his name was
sam sam miller i think and the people
used to call him the spam
so he would be one of mine he would be
one of the little agents that we send
out into the world
but yeah i mean the guys make good money
and they have a sense of belonging and
they can move their way up so i mean
we've got full-time members of staff now
we've got guys that do placement years
that have come and done graduate stuff
with us
and
yeah it's it's fun man it's really good
fun so what were you like in in school
to end up as that being your side hustle
rather than me ending up his website
design being my side hustle i was
probably a lot more like you in school
than you think really oh yeah yeah i'm
imagining you're a professional lad in
school and all the football teams all
the girls interested that kind of vibe
no no no very much a late bloomer so
school
was i played cricket at quite a high
level um for a long time throughout
pretty much all of school i went to a
state school state primary state
stockton sixth form college stockton
being a town that was only famous for
having the highest teen pregnancy rating
in the uk and it recently lost that so
it's not even the best at that anymore
and
um
yeah very much an unpopular kid in
school like wildly unpopular okay um
really on the outside looking in didn't
really fit into any particular groups
hey that was not like me for the record
okay okay
um
and then i think that what that
one of the advantages it gave me was
when i came to be a club promoter when
you're on the outside looking in you can
see how groups um coalesce okay and it
means that you can actually look at what
it is that they want from different
things and you can observe group
dynamics for uh markets in slightly
different ways okay so what we're
manipulating as club promoters is
group dynamics cool
trends uh how to bring people together
okay and it's i think it's far easier to
do that from the outside than from the
inside if you look at most top top level
club promoters guys that are of my level
they are
not people directly in the middle of the
popularity group the ones that are
slightly actually on the outside
because i think it gives them a bit more
perspective okay so as a club promoter
you figure out like who the cool kids
are you get them to come to your
nightclub you get them to build hype
around it the cool kids are going to
paradiso therefore they're slightly less
cool kids are like we want to be like
the cool kids are going to parody
you could be clipper mode sick
okay
um so you started off doing this as a
side hustle how did things like escalate
beyond that point to where where you are
now
uh so we just launched a saturday night
in newcastle that was very very
successful we timed it correctly with
the market and that became one of the
biggest events in the country it was
just as geordie shore had started so the
first ever episode of geordie shore
season one episode one they're in voodoo
which was our saturday night okay and we
ran that for six or seven years probably
did
a quarter of a million people through
that one event uh in that time maybe
even more and that gave us a foundation
that we could build on top of we could
recruit managers we learned our
processes so we very much structured and
made a procedure out of club promo as
best we could to try and have a formula
for how you release an event how you do
pre-build up to things and yeah that
informs a lot of the things that i do
now so
to give you an example
whenever i release anything to do with
my podcast or a new lead magnet or
courses that i do
i take huge advantage of
long lead times and teaser campaigns
because that is my club promotion
heritage right showing through i know
for a fact that if
we are
teleological beings right we look
forward to something occurring and we
actually enjoy the anticipation often a
lot more that we enjoy the event itself
so by having
i'm releasing a new lead magnet in seven
days time it's the modern wisdom reading
list
here's a countdown timer on instagram
here's some teaser pages of it coming
out this is why people have asked me to
do it this is what it's gonna look like
but you can't get it yet yeah this is
what it's gonna be like and it's just
different things maybe i'll talk about
it on the podcast maybe i'll bring it up
on instagram maybe i'll release a little
bit on twitter and then on that day you
get i i think that you end up with a
overclocked amount of demand and
interest because people have just been
like
waiting in the wings for it and we do
the same thing with club nights release
a teaser video for the teaser video then
release a teaser video then we do a
countdown then we finally get the event
out yeah and you turn up outside and
there's two thousand people because
they're just they're just curious about
what what's going on here why is this
happening so yeah long drawn out teaser
campaigns is a a great hack interesting
so when you say we put on like a club
night like what does what does the the
structure of this organization look like
cool so uh myself and my business
partner darren yep uh there's two
partners that are the parent company
that work with us in leeds matt and dave
yep below us we have about 12
managers below them there are about four
or five trainees junior managers and
below them there's about 500 guest list
staff so each manager has a team yep and
they similar to a sales team they
recruit them they find them so they'll
be on a night out and they'll see some
girl that's really hot or some guy
that's really cool or some like girl
that's got chat or whatever it might be
yep they'll say hey why are you in our
event you should be working for us and
then you get in for free and you get to
drink for free and you get to earn money
do you want to come work for us they
usually sometimes they say yes they
bring them on board and then that person
starts bringing their friends down guest
lister makes commission from their
friends attending manager makes
commission from all of their teams
commissions
and then we take the
door entry money over the top we're
going to take a very quick break to
introduce our sponsor brilliant
brilliant is a fantastic online platform
for learning maths science and computer
science with interactive and engaging
courses that i've been using for many
years but to be honest i wish i'd had
their lessons in maths to hand when i
was preparing for my bmat when applying
to medical school a lot of the time when
we're taught maths at school the focus
is on empty memorization of formulas
that we can apply in our exams but the
great thing about brilliant is their
courses teach you how to actually
understand concepts from a first
principles approach and develop the
intuition to solve problems also their
computer science series is absolutely
sick they've got some fantastic courses
on algorithms on learning to program
with python they've got a whole series
about cryptocurrency and understanding
exactly how things like bitcoin work
from the ground up which is genuinely
fascinating so if you want to give their
lessons and maths a try or even science
or computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up by
that link will get 20 off the annual
subscription to the website so thank you
so much brilliant for sponsoring this
episode so you so you're managing a
pretty large team
yeah it's huge
distributed distributed as in you've got
everybody is accountable to someone and
no one's team is actually that massive
so the the largest single um amount of
responsibility that any one person will
have will probably be about 30 to 40
people and that would be one of the
managers looking after a big team of
guest listers but they don't need
managing every day it's just are you
coming out tonight have you sent your
guest list in
you did [ __ ] last week you did well last
week you won an award here's a bottle of
vodka whatever nice
like if you're if you're this sort of
professional networker professional
party boy
do you form like real friendships
through that
or or like how how does the social
dynamics for you like your personal life
work when you end up with transactional
friendships from doing this yeah
absolutely but you know the ones that
are and people know why you're there as
well okay you transcend the friendships
especially with the people that you work
with so we have a voodoo old boys group
which is the guys that have graduated
and moved on some of them are being
financed people out in china now or some
of them are running stuff in london or
in manchester and we all keep together
and we bond really really closely so my
business partners wedding 50
plus of the people that were there were
people from nightlife mostly they were
the ones that we'd worked with there is
very much of them and us type uh kind of
like a
um what's it called in con artistry is
it like a mark and a con or something uh
there's the marks that are the people
that are going out and sometimes you
make good friends with those but for the
most part you bond with the people that
you work with okay but those friendships
you know you're going through
really intense experiences together if
you stand on the door of an event and
run 2 000 people trying to fit in on
halloween so we've got halloween coming
up um 2 000 people trying to get into a
venue and it will be chaos and people
are drunk people are throwing up people
are having fights there's
someone spilled something on the floor
some girl's fallen over and twisted her
ankle we need to get the whatever
whatever
it's a really strong bonding experience
with some people so you end up with a
small tight-knit group of friends and
then a very very sort of disparate group
of acquaintances interesting so i guess
it's sort of like how as a youtuber
you're not really friends with the
audience you're friends with other other
youtubers
precisely precisely correct and there is
this kind of parasocial relationship
between the audience and the youtuber
exactly the same
both parties know it's somewhat
transactional but we both know what this
is yes okay
that's so interesting okay um i so
how so you spent three years at uni
five five years
uh did bachelors with a year in industry
which was doing club promo for ourselves
we wrote ourselves a recommendation
letter and got awarded placement
students of the year off our own letter
um then
i went to do my master's in
international marketing the reason i did
that was because i was told that it
would be the easiest masters to do
because it was mostly my bachelor's just
bundled into another year uh i paid for
that in cash um so i went and paid eight
thousand one pounds actually in cash oh
wow because i'd saved up this money from
uh running club nights yeah and then
paid okay cash to the ladies uh and they
said oh the the safes only rated for 500
pounds i was like well the bank's still
open you think i'm not taking it back
you've got it um so that felt quite nice
i was able to self-fund my own master's
from running events that that was like
really really satisfying to me um
uh and then yeah five years at uni
take me out love island youtube yeah
okay
so take me out was your first
how did that foreign and what is taking
out for for the uninitiated it's a
modern day version of blind date it's a
very fluffy dating show here in the uk
guy walks out on stage there are
20 girls sat behind stood behind podiums
and they can keep their light on which
is i'm interested or they can turn their
light off which is he's not for me and
you go through different rounds where
you expose different pieces of
information about yourself so there'll
be a vt about your life there'll be uh
an explanation of what you do for work
they'll maybe interview one of your
friends
and whatever's left at the end whoever
has their lights on the guy then has the
power to choose who he wants to go on a
date with you're then flown off on
holiday for a day with the girl and you
spend a day
dating her
that's all televised as well and then
you decide whether or not you want to
keep in touch or not and then you go
home so it's actually quite the filming
thing is quite condensed yeah but um
that was fun and i'm a so i'm a male
model i've been alongside club promo and
doing youtube i've been a model since
pretty much i was 18. okay uh and i dj'd
as well so it was just anything that was
kind of like
it was the archetypal [ __ ] boy life
anything that made me look like a [ __ ]
boy and would earn me easy cash
that was for me so
you decide to do the male model thing
and then
the the take me out thing comes about
yep
what
if for example i got an email saying do
you want to be on take me out actually i
have i a few couple years ago i got and
some person messaged me on instagram
saying hey i'm a producer for like itv
something something something probably
one of the legions of them would you be
interested in coming on take me out like
a sort of doctor special edition yeah
and i was like hell no obviously not
because
it's a good question why because it
seems like cringe and scary and like
i think you do amazingly well
i think you do phenomenally well on
taking out especially as someone you
have to imagine how little time most
people have spent in front of a lens and
how poorly most people
deal with the pressure of being on
camera which is something that you
literally do for a living if you came
down the stairs and you understood your
positioning like you know who you are
you know what your offer to the market
is overall and you just leaned into that
a little bit and we're like hey guys i'm
ali i came first in cambridge this this
and this thing i'm a tech reviewer i do
this that and the other and actually on
the side i can play guitar and you pull
the guitar out and you start doing that
or you did your freestyle rap
dude you've nailed it i promise you
that's that's gold that is absolute
money okay but
just as you're as you're describing it
just even even the thought of that is
filling me with this sort of like
dread like you know i'm kind of i'm kind
of sweating i'm kind of thinking that i
don't want to be that guy i i think it's
a fear of what other people will think
other people who i know and people at
large will think of me because they'll
be like oh my god what the hell is this
um
did you have any of that when you went
on it were you just like screw it yeah
that's a good point um when you do take
me out specifically that's in front of a
400 person live audience which is really
really scary it doesn't matter that it
goes out to about four million people on
tv you don't think about them but 400
people in the audience that's pretty
scary
and also when you come down there's a
it's called the love lift when you come
down the love lift
that is the most rickety piece of [ __ ]
that has ever been created the fact that
that's got past health and safety blows
my mind so you started you stood on this
terrifying contraption as it slowly
allows you to the floor to be judged by
a group of 20 girls and watched by a
group of 400 people while paddy
mcguinness is next to you for people
that don't know paddy mcginnis is like a
xtv guy that now does uh top gear
doesn't he does he idea probably he
seems like i know him because he's a
person in articulate the board game and
i never know who he is it's like paddy
has like
i love how that's your reference into
like popular culture like first name
something power that like betting
company and then like the next one is
like a some kind of alcohol
they're like oh paddy beginners wow that
that would be how i describe it anyway
so yes uh how yeah how do you get over
that how did you get over that like
severe
i imagine anyone 99.99 of people
listening to this if they imagine
themselves on a reality tv show where
they're being judged by 20 girls and
broadcasting 4 million people at a 400
like person live audience would think
never in a million years am i doing that
yeah how like what was different about
you your mindset your approach that made
you be like you know what this is legit
this lesson isn't as satisfying as it
should be but it's it happens so much
you just end up doing it okay once
you're stood at the top of the lift and
you arrive at the bottom your feet end
up walking forward and you go but at
that point you will but like the point
where it's like you have to sign up for
this thing and you're kind of
visualizing you're imagining you
probably just didn't think about it
enough okay i didn't think about the
fact that i was going to be in front of
honestly dude i think that one of the
underrated productivity tools or life
tools that far few people use than
should do is yolo
just the fact that you can i'm just
gonna try this and see what happens yep
and just jump feet first and learn to
fly on the way down but i'm i've been
asked to go on this tv show
am i gonna be any good am i gonna
totally blow it
yolo and then you just do it like that
is
it's such an effective route for living
a very life because
you
you'll probably be fine yeah you'll
almost definitely be fine yeah
so just have faith that the future
version of you will sort it out and sure
enough that happens so yeah it's a bit
nerve-wracking before you're going to go
on and you think oh should i do i was 24
i was i didn't know anything about
breathing techniques i wasn't meditating
i wasn't doing cold plunges to try and
control my parasympathetic balance i
just thought i'll have a corona and hope
for the best so i had a beer backstage
and then before you know it you're stood
in front of girls and you're talking and
you're saying things and you realize wow
i didn't totally blow it it was just
normal and and
i survived and
didn't okay turn into a puddle of
anxiety on the floor
and then you go oh
that's fine
maybe i can do something else like that
you know it's either a good time or a
good story correct correct and
occasionally both um so that was that
was the take me out career at this point
you're you're you're 24.
um how what was happening next in your
life and where did love island come into
things so
that was just pure party boy modes
trying to build up the events business
so at this point did you start your own
events business this was we started that
when we were 22. okay so through twenty
three four years out into uni you were
like you know what let's do this thing
properly ourselves okay and you started
your business with your business partner
correct yeah so we've done a little bit
of work uh for other events companies
previous to that and dotted around but
it always been me and my business
partner i sat next to him in my first
ever seminar and we're still together 15
years later so i'm got rid of each other
and
that
has always been the single consistent
throughout which is
again trying to take give some takeaways
beyond yolo for this podcast
finding someone that you trust
absolutely
100 implicit
total trust is
such a competitive advantage i get
far far more than the 50 of the money
that we make that he takes from our
split from him because i just we know
each other inside out and and finding a
business partner that's like that it
really makes the
solo
entrepreneurs
even more impressive to me because i
think god like for you to be able to be
that person all of those decisions
there's no way that i would have been
able to do that with our business so
we're running our events uh i'm djing a
couple of nights per week i've done the
take me out thing which was just yolo
and clout and
we start launching other events we pick
up more and more networks so that
we can branch out we start to bring in
some more managers we learn to
relinquish control which is something
that every young businessman struggles
with you've got this baby that you've
built you understand exactly how it's
supposed to work i know exactly
where the inflatable's supposed to go
which railing it's supposed to be tied
around and what the sort of knot is
that's supposed to be used for it where
the cable ties go to put the banners on
the barriers that go outside to control
the queue no no no the cable tie is
supposed to go on that run not that
wrong because there's a little bit of a
crease you just you you know it inside
out yeah and then you need to learn okay
if i want to scale this business i need
to relinquish this control
and that's very difficult and we did
that
more slowly than was optimal okay i held
on to control
for longer than i should have done and
but over time we got used to it we
started to bring in more and more guys
that we trusted that could come in
underneath us we started to outsource
more and more of that workload picked up
more nights more events more entries per
night more staff more managers to manage
the staff and you just slowly build and
build and build over time how did you
kind of
how did you learn to
relinquish with a relinquished control
was there like a book was there like a
pivotal moment was it so at this at this
period man i'm a really good avatar for
the bro businessman okay up until about
four years ago right and
sometimes sometimes i think that with
the podcast that i do modern wisdom
does not
it doesn't speak to the person i used to
be
quite so much because i wasn't reading
books i wasn't bothered about personal
development i was bothered about
effectiveness in business and i was
happy to develop my own business
strategies but i was quite just in the
moment doing my thing and there wasn't
this sort of metacognizant step back to
look at it and
yeah that's a strategy
so jordan peterson was on the show and
he talked about this
about the ability to step back and look
at yourself i can give you the link to
put in the show notes if you want but
the the ability to step back and look at
it is something that i only developed
far later in life and when you're in it
the thinking i am going to let go of
this baby which is mine
it feels like someone's pulling
something out of you like pulling a a
child away from you and it's incredibly
difficult
but what we realized was if we want to
scale and grow the business i have to
learn to do this had i have read michael
gerber's the e-myth revisited that would
have been fine but i didn't i didn't
even know that existed right and even if
i had known that it had existed i would
have probably been eating dominoes and
drinking budweiser so i probably
wouldn't have been able to focus so i
wasn't in the right place to receive the
message even if i'd seen it
the other thing so two things right that
businessman young businessmen and women
really really need to remember the first
one is you can relinquish far more
control of your business than you think
the second one is you can raise your
price far more than you think
almost everyone is under charging for
their product almost everybody is doing
that because they are on the side of
terror
imposter syndrome comes through in the
way that you market yourself and you put
your products out there you don't think
that they're worth as much as they are
because you want to have demand
as opposed to profit sometimes that's
until you can have the equanimity to see
it from a bit more perspective right
but i was just so terrified of doing it
so yeah you can outsource far more of
the work that you're doing than you
think because you're holding on to it
too much and you can raise the price far
more than you think because you're
terrified of people not buying your
product i have i have a lot of
conversations with people about those
two exact points uh when it comes to
the uh the the outsourcing thing when it
comes to your usually creators or kind
of creative businesses where they would
they were the technician they were doing
everything by themselves and then the
thought of outsourcing editing oh my god
no one can edit like i can i have my
unique style of editing um therefore
kind of the fear of outsourcing it um
but every every single person i've
spoken to who has managed to outsource
editing says oh my god i freed up 30
hours of my life every single week to be
able to make more content or do the
things i want to do or spend more time
with my friend friends and family rather
than sit on final cut yes cutting out
pauses and um and adding b-roll here and
there um and on the pricing thing as
well i really had this fear when we
first launched our youtuber academy and
initially it was going to be like a 200
product self-paced i was like all right
i'm not i'm not going to suffer the risk
of a single person saying this is not
worth it or that i'm selling snake oil
therefore i'm going to overload them
with value and charge very very low
basically no money for it um and it was
speaking to a few of our mutual friends
uh tiago forte and david perrell who
talked me into not having this fear of
selling and recognizing that actually
you can raise the prices you can do it
as a more high touch thing and that
provides a specific service to people it
doesn't target everyone it's not going
to target the bulk of your audience but
that's okay and just that that feeling
of like oh [ __ ] what are people going to
think when i start charging real money
for something yeah
really scary serious so you you you're
finishing uni you're building up this
business scaling
what were the what was the motivation
there was it a kind of money thing a
status thing a prestige thing like why
why trying to scale business yeah good
question
so i think for a long time i found my
sense of self-worth in success in
business this was probably not having
tons of success socially when i was
younger and me wanting to prove to the
world that i'm worth something that i
can have people need me that i have
monetary success that i have accolade i
have renown prestige status that i'm
being i'm sleeping with the right girls
that i'm spending time with the right
friends that i'm standing on the door of
the correct clubs like these were the
things that were giving that were making
me feel like i was worth something in
the real world and that was i mean don't
get me wrong it's pretty satisfying it's
pretty good at satisfying you on a
surface level okay and it can go for a
fair while and i like rode that until
the wheels came off but then i did love
island and that was when i was 28
27
and
um the same casting director that worked
on take me out also worked on love
island did exactly the same thing hey
man i need someone for this new show can
you come and just screen test for me
yeah sure i will and before i knew it i
was
in a pair of swim shots in the back of a
jeep about to go into a build that's
literally how it worked hey man can you
come and stream screen test in newcastle
i just want to ask you some questions
yeah whatever mate like we became
friends
i'll do that and then
i had the most
thorough sexual health and psychometric
evaluation that you've ever seen in your
life uh in harley street somewhere in
london and then literally before i knew
it as i um okay so what is love island
for the uninitiated uh it is kind of
like a cross between big brother and the
bachelor
the bachelor in paradise if you watch
the american version it's a dating show
people get thrown into a villa and there
is usually about 14 to 20 guys and girls
at 10
between 10 and 7 of each and you have
half the number of beds that you do
people so
everyone has to couple up you couple up
with a partner and then you swap and
then there's eliminations and there's
tasks and it's all about people that are
trying to find love supposedly and
every so often there's eliminations and
you get to the end and then there is a
prize for the people that win of 50 000
pounds or something like that
and i did i was the first person through
the doors of season one so the first
ever person through on this particular
iteration of the
of the series and that was just another
yolo is that right this will get me
clout this will get me accolade clout
clout is in clout uh renown status and i
thought
it'll be fun free holiday okay good time
yeah
why not do it yeah uh yes i did so these
days love island is like ridiculously
huge uh at least in the uk i don't know
i don't know internationally but um the
people who are on love island then and
the 50 000 is nothing compared to the
millions of followers they'll get on
instagram
endlessly you don't need to work for
probably five to ten years after you've
been on if you're on for a couple of
weeks so what was it like back in the
day kind of season one what was it very
difficult so um and they were focusing
the first season they focused on
snapchat a lot whereas now it's all
instagram which was great because it
means you can monetize your instagram
off the back of it we didn't know if it
was going to be like geordie shore or x
on the beach where you were going to be
getting drunk every night and going on
nights out or if it was going to be like
big brother then it was going to be
tasks and you were going to have food
taken away from you and your sleep
pattern was going to be it ended up
being quite fluffy but we didn't know
that i also didn't know you could have
someone manage your social media while
you were inside so i just had my
instagram locked off
so people could follow me or whatever
but so anyway uh very different don't
get as much attention as you do now now
if you're on for as long as i was you
would come out with probably one or two
million followers and
if you can correctly monetize that that
you're sorted yeah it blows my mind
here's the thing
for the people that may have been on
love island that are watching that were
on season
two to three or after and were on for
more than a couple of weeks if you
haven't built a business off the back of
that and you wanted to
that's a you problem yeah you had
what every marketer every internet
marketer desires which is three clicks
for
a long time and a huge amount of edge
rank
and just didn't monetize it but for us
we i think the person that one came off
with a hundred thousand
uh followers on instagram which now even
if your name gets mentioned even if
someone says oh do you watch the ali
abdullah on youtube that's a hundred
thousand that's 100 000 followers there
um so yeah it was
smaller in terms of viewership smaller
in terms of footprint digitally yeah um
but was a really interesting experience
yeah what was the experience like it's
actually quite boring to be honest
because you all that you're allowed to
talk about
is
stuff that's happened in the villa so
you can't actually talk about
that mutual friend you've both got
that's outside or that place that you
both like to go to to run or to go for
coffee or for almond croissants or
whatever can't talk about that and they
will come over the pa and say islanders
can you please stop talking about the
outside world because they can't publish
that content because who that's watching
the show gives a [ __ ] about the fact
that mini both like almond croissants no
one cares what they care about is the
fact that me and you were fighting over
katie and she totally mugged you off
last night bro like that's what they're
bothered about okay so that's what they
try and push they're constantly asking
you to create content okay and that's
fine they don't
finesse or finagle the story lines too
much they try and catalyze them a little
bit but they don't really
impose themselves in terms of what's
happening yep but it's pretty boring
you've got no friends no phone no family
no contact with the outside world
nothing to distract you no books no
nothing it's just you and some people
that are trying to have sex with each
other constantly talking about who's
having sex with who that's it that's
what the show is and
it's it was kind of i guess it was an
interesting thing to watch
but this was the pinnacle of me getting
toward the end of my 20s
and the guys that are listening may feel
this as well it's what i call the mano
pause oh which is
toward the end of your 20's if you've
grown up living quite a broly life
what i think a lot of guys find is that
the values that serve them when they
were in their early 20s maybe 21 are not
going to serve them when they're 31 and
they realize this quite profoundly
sometimes so you see this i first
noticed it with training so guys would
do uh bodybuild bodybuilding style
training because it's the lowest barrier
to entry gives them confidence it makes
them bigger and more muscular and it
makes them feel attractive but as they
get towards 28 29 they realize that they
get out of breath going up a set of
stairs and that they can't touch their
toes and they haven't really been that
functional and maybe they get back into
playing football with some mates and
they realize that they've just got no
cardio and they're not very functional
so then you see guys that are toward the
end of their 20s they'll go and do
crossfit or they'll go do brazilian jiu
jitsu or fighting or yoga or girls might
go back and do dance that they haven't
done since they were a kid they might
start doing ballet again or go and do
those um
pilates classes group pilates classes
spinning
what i realized there was that there are
particular modes of existing that we get
in our early twenties many of which are
kind of the lowest common denominator um
limbic hijack route to success that we
can find right like quite a base
transactional transient route to success
i want a training methodology that's
going to make me look good i will do the
one that makes me look the most good but
does it fulfill you and make you feel
good i don't care if it makes me feel
good i just want to look nice okay
as you grow up a little bit more you
realize hang on perhaps this isn't
serving me quite in as much of a
holistic broad view as i want that's
what i saw with fitness what i think you
see with specifically guys maybe with
girls as well the mano pause is someone
realizing that as you get toward the end
of your 20s the values that you had when
you were younger aren't serving you so
me
realizing that the girls that i was
sleeping with or the money that i was
making or the club nights that i was
running
is that really the highest calling that
i have for myself is the fact that i've
been on a reality tv show going to be my
crowning achievement is this what i'm
bringing to the world oh well you know
the world was pretty bad before he came
but after he left at least he went
unloaded reality tv shows like come on
so
while i was on love island i got to
observe people that were that person the
pinnacle party boy right because i was
playing this role i thought i was but it
kind of turned out that i wasn't really
and i had this fatal dose of contrast as
i lived in a villa with no distractions
for four weeks watching these people and
being with them but really still feeling
on the outside so i was like right there
is a problem here i thought i was this i
thought i was this party going
fun-loving extroverted big name on
campus big dick around town guy
and i'm not
there's something up here
so after that was when i thought right i
really need to do some self inquiry and
kind of work out
who am i what are my values why am i
here
now
i feel like
because of the proliferation of podcasts
and self-development and personal growth
youtube and stuff like that
people getting exposed to these sorts of
messages at a much younger age but it
took me until i was 27 for me to
actually really think probably need to
work out like who i am and that
and then got to coming out of love
island and the final night came out
after about a month um looked up at the
sky in the south coast of majorca
uh which is one of the uh
astronomy um spots of the world low
light pollution high visibility
uh no moon and i saw the full milky way
for the first time and that was quite a
profound experience because i'd been in
this really intense emotional thing and
i hadn't seen anyone spoken to anyone
stepped outside first night on my own
without cameras on me for a month
looked up at the sky and saw the milky
way and i'd had this weird sort of
existential
discordant thing going on where i
thought who am i i'm not this per looked
up i thought [ __ ] right okay i just need
to do some self work here so that was
kind of
the uh kick toward my monopoles so what
happened then
i did some self work spent a lot of time
just
crushing amounts of content
school of life bylander bottom sam
harris joe rogan jordan peterson this
was when all of these people were coming
to the front and
didn't really know what i was looking
for but just thought if i watch enough
of it something will come out of it and
it kind of did and then a year and a
half later i'd been asked on a bunch of
different podcasts because people had
said oh
you've been on this reality tv thing can
we ask you about that i was like oh yeah
what's a podcast cool i'll come and do
that really enjoyed the process
enjoyed it so much that i realized i
want to do this more the best way for me
to do as much as i want to is to start
my own so i started my own and that was
start of 2018.
in that one year gap between
being on love island uh sort of when you
were consuming all this content and
stuff
what were the
like what were the learnings from that
like tell the truth was the first one
the most important one
i'd spent a very long time
playing a persona on the front door of
this nightclub right
a lot of nightclubs
in manchester and in newcastle working
about a thousand nights and being chris
the club promoter being the guy that
sorts him out with guest list and all he
shagged my may and blah blah blah being
that guy and
what i realized was that that was a role
that i was playing that wasn't a genuine
representation of the person that i was
i was being the person that i thought
other people wanted me to be because it
was effective and it was
i was
world class at playing chris williamson
on the front door of a nightclub like
literally oscar-winning performance but
it wasn't me that wasn't the person i
genuinely was
so
i needed to unearth and sort of scrape
away all of the different personas that
i had that were lying over the top of
the person that i genuinely was and that
involved turning over tons and tons of
different stones and looking at what was
underneath and going okay here's a
belief that i have about the world
here's something that i think is this
true
and i'd spent so long lying to myself
and to other people about what i
genuinely wanted and what my values were
yeah mate mint tonight mate yeah there's
a lot of birds in there mate yeah see
you later on me like all of that for for
a decade
when that wasn't really uh my logos
speaking forward right that wasn't my
truth coming out of me that was me just
doing something i needed to get past all
of that so i'm doing this archaeology
thing going like right am i gonna hit
something that's solid as i try to
unearth all of the different behaviors
and the thinking patterns and the
beliefs that i've got
and that eventually i got to
something that felt a little bit more
stable which was intellectual curiosity
i decided to learn and improve myself i
decide to sort of connect with people
around me a genuine desire to be open
and vulnerable
and to show other people that being open
and vulnerable and truthful is something
that can help them and makes them feel
good
but it took
over a year it took
18 months for me to even start to really
glimpse that what sort of questions were
you asking yourself like what do you
mean by like what does this unearthing
process look like in practice
a lot of it was just thinking about how
do i spend my time
does that
is that the way that i want to spend my
time does that serve the person that i
want to be so i wake up at different
times every day like is that the sort of
does the chris that i want to become
wake up at different times every day
okay i
pay uh i i
take a high amount of self-worth from
the amount of people that go into my
club night
should i
be
hinging my self-worth on what the market
does probably not that's probably a bad
idea but it took me a long time it
sounds so dumb looking back and going
like obviously mate like
you and the performance of your event
and business are not the same thing it
is not you and its success or failure
does not um
make any sort of change to your worth as
a person
but that's the world that i create for
myself that's a that's a hard
realization um i remember when i was in
school where i was equating my personal
self-worth to how well i did in exams
and then at university to how well my
business did and then even now
well i i had i had a whole like five
hours of soul searching typing
journaling on apple notes
four days ago where i was like oh my god
i take too much self-worth away from how
well my videos do like i think this
i love how kind of open you're being
about this but but i think this this
journey of like dissociating our
self-worth from these other random
bullshitty external metrics
it's not an easy one and i think i think
it's a lifelong journey for all of us
here's a question for you man do you
think that people love you for what you
do or for who you are
i've been
so over the last few months i i really
thought it was for what i do especially
when it came to friend friendship and
stuff
um i thought that
i just didn't quite
i thought it was the things that i was
doing um
that were the reasons why people wanted
to be friends with me and it was
it was surprising when i mentioned this
to a few friends and they were like
no you actually don't need to do any
like
because
if i think about
the people i'm friends with i'm not
friends with them for what they do i'm
friends with who they are and it took
other people pointing out to me that
well that's how other people feel about
you for me to think oh my god and that
was quite like a profound realization
for me and made me realize that i can
just sort of be myself but but before
i'd been like uh be yourself it's all
just bs because like choose yourself and
and all that kind of stuff i got another
question yeah do you love yourself for
who you are or what you do
oh good question i think i love myself
for what i do yeah so here's the problem
right
we want the world to love us for who we
are not for what we do we don't want
people to love our achievements we want
to feel like we're worth something
ourselves yep
however we love ourselves
for what we do not who we are so we're
asking the world to do something that we
don't do ourselves i want you to love me
for who i am not what i do
meanwhile i'ma love myself for what i do
not who i am because i feel like when i
achieved something that i feel like i'm
worth something more to myself when i
hit that next subscriber count when i
get that
gold plaque
diamond plaque when i hit a new best
number of plays when i get more people
on my academy when i put more people
into my club night when i sleep with a
more popular girl when i hit a new
number of
followers on instagram
all of these different metrics are
things that are hiding the fact that we
don't want to give ourselves self love
for what it is that we who we genuinely
are what do what do you mean by love
yourself
feel comfortable and feel like you are
sufficient
independent
of how you perform day-to-day in the
world
the fact that you
stripped of all of your achievements
youtube channel's gone podcast's gone
degrees are gone
all of that stuff are you isolated and
strip bear still worth something to the
world and do you feel like people would
still love you and still care about you
that's a good question
it's a difficult one it's a very
difficult one so i got that realization
from aubry marcus another this anyone
that's resonating with this i'll give
you the link for this episode with aubry
he's just sold on it to unilever for a
huge undisclosed number like hundreds of
millions of dollars right
the link will be in the show notes below
he said
he'd bolstered his entire life with sex
and money so he'd spent his entire life
chasing women and trying to earn
he's just sold his company for a hundred
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars and he's just got married
what's left for him all of the things
that he used to be chasing now he's
completed them and he had an existential
crisis
because he said all of these things that
i thought would fulfill me i've now done
it
so who am i i'd wrapped up so much of my
self-worth in the fact that i was
chasing this dream dragon of a woman and
of a
figure in my bank account
and now it's got to the stage where
actually who am i without all of that
or who am i once all of that's been
completed
and this comes back to
what happened when
i first started a business and again
this is
another element for young business
people
if you attach your sense of self-worth
to the success of the business you are
on a path toward misery the reason is
that
you don't get to control the [ __ ]
market right the market will do what the
market will do and it does not give one
single [ __ ] about you it doesn't care so
why would you say that your self-worth
is based on
trends in the market you're literally
externalizing your sense of well-being
to other people
that's the same as that's the same as
people that leave notifications on their
phone
it's exactly the same okay you're
allowing the entire world anybody on the
planet to intrude on your day whenever
they want this is the same with your
business you're allowing the response of
the market to determine your self-worth
every time that you put a product out or
run an event or release a youtube video
if you feel crap when your youtube video
underperforms but feel amazing when your
youtube video overperforms that's fine
that's
realistic you care about performing well
but if you genuinely feel like you are
worth more
or worth less
that's
a different step you've crossed a line
there and this is something that i still
fight with all the time i'd still
struggle with it this is me
understanding the path but not having
completed the path
so you're on this kind of a 12 to 18
month journey of self-discovery and you
said that one of the things that helped
is asking yourself
is this thing that i'm doing consistent
with the person that i want to be yes um
what were some other
things that you figured out about
yourself along that that path not
telling the truth was it was a huge one
um that i'd just been
people would ask me my opinion on
something and i would tell them what i
thought they wanted to hear okay not
what i genuinely believed because i
presumed that that would make them like
me because i just wanted to be liked and
this was funded or fueled by being a
club promoter which is very transient
and transactional and there is a degree
of performative
uh nature on the front door of a club
night if someone says all right mate how
are you and you go actually man my dog
just died and blah blah blah blah blah
no i just want you to say yes and give
me a stamp and go let me in so
there is
that was reinforced by work
some of the other things were mostly to
do with opening up and being being
vulnerable because i was
in a
hyper masculine
very cool guy world
and
it wasn't
it wasn't
how would you say conducive to
having a bad day and opening up to
someone about it it's another challenge
as well for anyone that's a business
owner or at the top of the tree that's
listening
you can feel like because you are the
head of your business
that showing any form of weakness shows
a weakness in the business
that if you underperform or you have a
bad day that the people who look up to
you your subordinates and your employees
within the business
will see you
as less
will see you as unworthy of leading them
because who's whose leader would spend a
couple of days in bed because he's
feeling down about whatever might have
occurred um
another thing that i realized was
working
working so hard
that you have a miniature breakdown
which for me manifested is being in bed
for a couple of days and i just
couldn't be bothered to get out and it
felt like depression but i think it was
just
like
small acute breakdowns
it always happened around freshers week
so
one month of constant build up constant
build and this is when i'd stopped
partying so much as well
releasing event after event after event
all on social media then going and
working on the night
four or five hours sleep then get up the
next day go to the office make sure that
everything was sorted run another event
fill it cash the tills go home do the
next thing oh is this working this djs
cancel blah blah blah just constant
intensity
start of october every single year i
would always spend a couple of days in
bed why why is it that i always end up
feeling a little bit sort of shitty
after this
because
going so hard you end up snapping
is not a sustainable
work protocol just doesn't it you can't
keep doing that and expect to get
consistent results
and
punishing yourself because you don't
have the tolerance it's like having eyes
that are bigger than your stomach it's
like having an appetite for work which
is bigger than your capacity for work
and this is something in a productivity
world look i'll get more i'll just get
more done um
that is a route toward disaster for
chris sparks says in order to pick
something up you have to put something
down and the presumption is
if i want to be more productive i will
just down regulate my sleep or up
regulate my efficiency until i fit this
new thing in yeah
but you're already working close to your
maximum capacity because if you weren't
you would be doing more
most people that are driven type a
personalities are already working close
to their capacity and then when you
because you see all of your own
inefficiencies right you think yeah but
i spent 30 minutes a day on youtube so
if i add this new thing in i'll just get
rid of that 30 minutes it's like no the
30 minutes a day on youtube is there
because you need a [ __ ] break from
all the work you're doing
that's going to stay when you add this
in the place it's going to come off of
is going to be optional things that
really matter like spending time with
friends and family like chilling out on
a weekend like getting more sleep that's
what's going to really really sting
so
those are some of the realizations work
less open up more be truthful
realize that you have curiosities and
intellectual desires and stuff that
maybe don't align with the person that
you thought you were
and a final one was
i'd never really connected with any of
the success of the business not in a
meaningful way not in an existential way
i'd felt
proud that we'd achieved a lot and had
tons of people come to the event and
that felt mint but
i never i never really really felt it
and i think the reason for that was
if you're playing a persona i was club
promo chris um
you don't feel like your achievements
are yours you feel like they're people
applauding a character that you're
playing
so
the same way that we don't love russell
crowe we love gladiator we don't love
chris hemsworth we love thor you're
always one step removed from the things
that you're doing if you're not being
truthful and open whereas if you do
something that is genuinely you
putting yourself out into the world when
someone says ali i really love what
you've done with this and that's your
truth you go that's me
as opposed to ali i really love what
you've done with youtube or ally over
here you go yeah well done youtuber ally
like pat on the back for you and that's
the difference between doing something
that feels fulfilling existentially yeah
and doing something that just feels like
pride
so interestingly on that on that point
um yesterday we put out a video uh the
first one in a while on the channel
where i felt it was like authentically
me i didn't really have a script just
have it had a few talking points 45
minutes long me just rambling about
stuff
and the response to that video was just
insane and i was going through all the
comments and the comments were really
nice and i woke up early this morning
uh i did the thing that you shouldn't do
and grabbed my phone and i was like you
know what let's see how the comments are
doing i'm just like oh it's so nice
hotting every single one and i haven't
read youtube comments in months because
i've uh and and hearing you say that
made me realize that the videos that i
think we've been putting out over the
last few months haven't really felt
particularly authentic it felt like i
was playing a character whereas this one
i was like alright you know what i
should do it basically uncut
felt so much more authentic and so the
comments really resonated with me more
than a comment on a video that i felt uh
i mean i had the idea but like someone
else wrote the script for it it kind of
vibes yeah um
i wanted to talk to you about
masculinity
this is something that i struggle with
and i think you're an interesting person
to talk to about this because you seem
to not
worry about
coming across as woke
or like you know saying the right thing
you know
saying things that fit into the overton
window of acceptability and you know
some of the stuff on the podcast some
people say is somewhat controversial um
and so i'd love to hear your take on
like what
what's what's the deal with like
masculinity like just a broad broad open
question and i i have a few kind of sub
questions that i'd like to ask but can
we
what's your thesis on masculinity it's
an interesting one i think
it's a word that has been co-opted to
mean a lot of different things now
you're right with
some of the people that i have on the
show
on modern wisdom which is my podcast um
their views perhaps go against a
progressive orthodoxy that exists at the
moment
that being said i don't think that
they're tremendously controversial i've
never ever been on the verge of any sort
of cancellation or really
i don't get negative comments on the
videos the vast majority of people that
watch the show
they understand that i'm coming from a
place of in genuine intellectual
curiosity and trying to understand
things that being said
i think that it is very difficult to
have a
wholesome role model as a young guy at
the moment i don't think that
young men know
what they should grow up to be and by
that i mean what sort of a man what sort
of values they should have
i
wholeheartedly agree that the metoo
movement was a long overdue reckoning
for men in positions of power that used
those positions in order to get sexual
access in order to manipulate women
that was something that had to happen
that being said
you can't throw the baby out with the
bathwater and say that any masculine
traits are part of a cis hetero
patriarchal construct that runs below
the surface of everything that we see
and these are oppressive patriarchal
ideas to do with
gender and misogyny and gender roles and
blah blah blah
what you end up there with is
men who make up 50 of the entire world's
population not knowing what the [ __ ] to
do with their life they don't know what
they're supposed to do how they're
supposed to exist in the world
we've already got rid of religion
so
some of the things that gave us a sense
of meaning have gone we've got rid of
jobs for life which meant that our craft
we might have been a
stone mason or a builder or a farmer or
something that worked with our hands
where we could see our physical
creations in front of us and this is for
women as well those things have gone for
everybody and then when you say okay
and the things that you used to rely on
to do with masculinity things like
competence hard work courage bravery
trustworthiness
industriousness conscientiousness when
these things are also perhaps lambasted
and labeled negatively
that doesn't really give men
much of a place to stand you go okay so
what what am i supposed to
what what is a man now
we're not getting into the gender debate
what is a masculine portrayal
of somebody's personality like what are
the characteristics that make someone
masculine that are positive
and that's a kind of a difficult
question to answer so when it comes to
masculinity from my side
i just know that i'm an only child right
so i had no older brother um our
generation's gaps my parents generation
is quite large a lot of the rules and
the procedures that our parents had
don't really work for us so role models
in terms of your parents you're also a
little bit of a distance away from that
there's a delta to work there and i
didn't know what i wanted to be and
you've just heard a story about how most
of my 20s as someone who did two degrees
at uni who can be an idiot but isn't a
complete idiot was lost really really
lost so i think
right i i want to try and give young
guys the advice that i wish that i'd had
when i was younger and this isn't
real social dynamics pickup artists that
weirdo stuff it's not negging and
neuro-linguistic programming to get
girls to go to bed with you it's
how are you a confident person in the
world as a man that feels proud about
yourself that's proud about your
masculinity that's proud about the
achievements that you've got that
doesn't mind about being vulnerable but
doesn't identify with being vulnerable
you know finding somewhere to stand i
think has uh
has been a difficulty why do we need
concepts like masculinity and femininity
why can't we just say you know what
courage bravery confidence
being
integrity honesty these are all
universally good qualities and therefore
we should strive for these universal
good qualities and not label them
some of the masculine and some of them
feminine for example because men and
women aren't the same
they're not the same
for all that deconstructionist ideology
may wish that they were the same they're
not there are certain things that men
have a proclivity toward and there are
certain things that women have a
proclivity toward okay on average
on average it does not mean that you
cannot get masculine women in feminine
men it does not mean that this girl that
i know is really really masculine and
she's more masculine than you are yeah
i'm sure that there very well may be but
those are outliers if you were to throw
them across
we also need them because we live our
life through archetypes
we look to people as examples
and
for the most part we model ourselves on
stories we model ourselves why when you
watch the big bang theory do you
immediately know what each character is
the
hero's big chested and muscled and has a
large jaw and the nerd always wears
glasses and there's the damsel and the
villain the villain's always in black or
he's got a fringe or something it's
because we need to be able to shortcut
our way to understand what people are
about and when we're trying to design
our own lives as well we also look to
archetypes from history
i think that it's an important
learning procedure
for both men and women
to have role models that they can look
up to and i don't know at the moment
that there are very many well-accepted
role models for men to look up to for
all that harry styles is an awesome
singer i don't know that every man wants
to be harry styles not every man wants
to be
like the rock either but you have to
have some role models for guys to look
up to
so
there also needs to be a synthesis what
is the average on average
what is a good principle for men to try
and achieve the same thing goes for
women um and my concern is that we've
thrown a lot of baby and bathwaters out
it's easier for me to to make an example
with girls than it is with guys for this
so for instance women being encouraged
to have careers over families
is something that absolutely
should be a choice for them and
if you are a go get a girl that is
that's sick more power to you
however
i think that you need to be an
incredibly unique woman to make it to 50
look back without a family and say that
it was a good decision
that is not to say that there are not
women out there for whom it is the
perfect decision
but i think that you need to be quite a
unique woman for that to be the case
great
pushing
every woman should have a career should
prioritize their career you don't need
no man you shouldn't settle for less
clap back you're a boss [ __ ]
and almost creating an environment in
which
women who do prioritize families over
careers are seen as compromising
toward a
archaic view of what a woman should be
when a lot of women take very very
high large amounts of pleasure from
raising a family
i don't think that that's tremendously
respectful to
the women that want to go and do that
there is a a framing to the situation
that presumes that going and getting a
career is the thing that everybody
should should endeavor to achieve
and that's not to say that men can't
stay at home and be the the primary
uh how would you say child carer but
in relationships where the man is not
the primary breadwinner they are 50 more
likely to end in divorce in
relationships where the man is not the
primary breadwinner he is statistically
more likely to need to use erectile
dysfunction medication almost two-thirds
of women say that they would not be in a
relationship with a man who is less
educated less wealthy and lowering
status than them
if this seems like it's a bizarre set of
statistics
think about if you're a girl think about
would you date a man that's shorter than
you
maybe okay would you date a man that is
10 inches shorter than you well probably
not well okay that is just the same but
ported across onto status and wealth and
education as well
i think
overall
a man needs to be three or four from
taller richer smarter and more status
you can get away with being a short guy
who's rich smart with high status or you
can get away with being a tall guy with
status who's maybe not rich yet but is
well educated if you're only getting two
of those four you're starting to
struggle this isn't to say
that women are callous resource
extractors right what it's to say is
that women like men who are on average
trustworthy hardworking conscientious
they're the sort of man that you can
depend on that will get things done and
if you have status intelligence through
education and wealth that is a signal
that you have these things but what
we've been told is that if a man is to
try and achieve status wealth or
education he shouldn't go and do it
that is
him sticking to an out of
uh personality type that men no longer
needs need to adhere to there's like a
few things going on here there's number
one
that um
men and women are different and while
both men and women exhibit all traits
across all the spectrums spectra
whatever
men are on average higher in
ape in some traits and women are on
average higher in other traits yes and
are we saying that it's those traits
that are that we can broadly
label with all the caveatting that goes
with broadly late trying to label
anything based on like large numbers as
like masculine traits and feminine
traits i would say so yeah so for
example masculine like men are on
average higher on trait aggression or
or conscientiousness i guess
less so on empathy less on caringness
more so on competitiveness
um
less on warmth
and so men are interested in things
women are interested in people
and
so when it comes to i guess with the
role model role model discussion um
yeah for some reason it like
no one bats an eye at the fact that
people want role models of their own
race you often hear people say that oh
there are no black x in whatever or
there are no pakistani whatever there
are no chinese people in films and
therefore
asian people lack a role model of that
of that particular type
and i guess what
is
i guess when it comes to
role models in general it's
it's it's
it's very hard for someone to have a
role model who's not like them
like
i guess the anti-gender
anti-masculinity femininity
brigade would say that if i'm looking
for a role model i should be just as
likely to choose a female role model as
a male role model
which is just unlikely
um similarly
a woman is very unlikely like
i don't know a white woman is very
unlikely to have a black man as there as
their role model are you for example me
as a role model yeah and so is what
you're saying that as a as a dude it's
hard to find
because i guess we if we think about
like who who who would be in the running
as like role model james bond famously
but then the whole misogyny stuff which
means that james bond is not allowed as
a role model
the rock potentially
a pretty good show yeah
the rock's a guy who is able to
tick a lot of boxes like when you're the
guy that's
simultaneously able to be
top in an action movie
and potentially president of the united
states like there's a campaign to make
the rock the president of the united
states like you've done a lot right you
got a lot right um yeah you correct with
the rock you know he's in touch with his
own emotions but even that sort of thing
i i haven't seen any criticisms of the
rock maybe he's like the outlier that
proves the rule i'm not sure
i think that the challenge is
if you don't have any role models people
get lost i think that there are a lot of
role models for how girls should behave
at the moment and there's a lot of
support for girls and rightly so for a
very very long time there wasn't girls
weren't encouraged to do whatever they
want but
it feels a little bit like men are not
being encouraged to do whatever they
want now and that's not whatever they
want that is
to
try and achieve in the world in a way
that they think is going to make them
feel fulfilled we've talked a little bit
a little bit about like about the dating
marketplace and
you've touched on the thing the
the traits that women on average look
for in men are
different
than you know the traits that women on
average look for men on average look for
in women correct and i guess
what you're given that you have sort of
experienced the professional party boy
lifestyle you've been on take me out
you've been on love island
what's your
what's your take on like what are we
what are the things that men in general
seem to like in women and and vice versa
cool on average this is before every
single sentence right on average
everything in this episode
on average
um on average
men are interested in youth and
fertility from women on average women
are interested in resources from men
this is
shown out in a number of different ways
why is it that throughout all of time
the
uh optimal weight for women in terms of
what's culturally being seen as
attractive does fluctuate so across
different cultures and across different
ages it fluctuates however the waist to
hip ratio always remains the same around
about 0.8 why is that well it's because
a high waist to hip ratio is a signal of
fertility why is it that girls who have
bigger eyes and flusher cheeks tend to
be seen as more attractive well it's
because bigger eyes and fleshy cheeks
are associated with youthfulness and
youthfulness is associated with
fertility
women who have more symmetrical faces
are more fertile which is why we are
attracted to symmetry it's also
more costly in order to be able to grow
a symmetrical face than a
non-symmetrical face which is why we're
attracted to that as well
spin it around in the other direction
men's body sizes have changed
over time exactly the same but the
optimal shoulder to waste ratio for men
almost exactly stays the same why is
that it shows that you can get excess
calories on top of what you need who
cares about excess calories we have more
calories than we need yes but not for
almost all of our revolutionary past for
almost all of time men were underfed not
overfed and if you could show that look
i have so much access to resources and
food that i can sustain this stupid big
body with these big shoulders and this
small waist that is that's a good sign
um
the dynamics and the way that this bears
out is so interesting and
it's difficult to not sound like you're
trying to make prescriptions for
people's relationships which is not what
i'm doing i find it fascinating
endlessly fascinating to look at the
dating market and to look at why people
like the things that they do
the difference in right swipes on tinder
for a man with a bachelor's degree
versus a master's degree is the master's
degree gets 90 more right swipes that's
all that you need to do so if you're
thinking about doing a master's degree
and you want to get more right swipes on
tinder as a guy just do it um for every
15 iq but for every standard deviation
that a woman's intelligence increases
over about 110 to 115 every standard
deviation which is about 12
her chance of getting married goes down
quite significantly
it's about 20 to 30
for each standard deviation chance of
marriage continues to drop
and
why is this well it's because women tend
to want to date a man that is richer
smarter and more successful than she is
they date up and across it's called
hypergamy so
if you are atop your own dominance
hierarchy quite rightly so you as a
woman should be able to go and achieve
as much as you want start your own
business be as educated with a phd and a
thousand people that work for you make a
billion pounds
but if your fundamental attraction is to
men that are higher in status wealthier
and more intelligent than you are how
are you going to date across and above a
dominance hierarchy if you sit on the
top of your own if you're the richest
smartest best status woman on the planet
who's above you that's a man there's no
one
so
high performing women narrow their own
dating pool sadly and this is a real
difficulty it's like being the tall
friend
if you have a girl friend who is six
foot two
she's probably stuck looking at
professional athletes
if she wants to date on average women
like to date a man that's about 20 20
centimeters taller than them that seems
to be the optimal height difference
if you're six foot two as a girl
you've narrowed your own dating pool
because you are so tall the equivalent
happens with earning the equivalent
happens with education because typically
you want to date someone that is above
and across i think the height example is
interesting because
i think when you say uh
i've i've i've had these sorts of
conversations so so often with people
and when you use things like
intelligence or iq well oh but like oh
of you know iq's iq's been debunked and
intelligence is not really a thing
because it's all a social construct when
you use things like um when you use any
kind of personality trait it's like oh
but that's socially predetermined like
obviously that's not a thing but as soon
as you use the height example people are
like oh [ __ ]
rubbers met the road now yeah yeah
really well i mean
yeah for the people who don't
believe
in
gender differences to do with
personality and to do with attraction
i'm not speaking to those people um
this may be interesting to them uh but
they're not
on the same
plane of talking that i am right now um
there's some asymmetries that occur in
the dating market that are really unfair
uh one of them is
the fact that
men are allowed to be as sexually
liberal as they want when they're young
and that women aren't that
sucks for women not so much for men
but
the single biggest predictor of
extramarital sex is pre-marital sex
single biggest predictor
probably confounded by the fact that
very religious people wouldn't have
pre-marital sex and
yeah yeah good point in fairness um
but
with that in mind yeah what you see is a
myth that's unfortunate also being
reflected in reality in terms of what
your preferences would have been so most
people don't want to be with a partner
that's going to cheat on them
that means that
you have
an awkwardness when you're in your youth
because you need to think okay like
over my shoulder is someone kind of
watching to see how many people i sleep
with am i am i judging my sense of self
worth on how many how many people i
sleep with that's something that
i think that would be great to get past
for women i think that that would
emancipate women from it but the problem
is the desire is still going to be there
like if you found out that your
girlfriend had slept with
a number of people or 10 times that
number of people
it's very difficult for you to not feel
some sort of a difference to that but i
don't know if the same thing happens in
reverse from girls with guys so
for all that something maybe a social
construct we may be able to do some some
good work to de-program this and to be
able to help liberate women like when
the rubber meets the road
it's going to be hard to actually stop
that from happening
yeah i think
i think you and i share uh
an academic interest in the dating
market because it really is
where
preferences are
realized
great way to put it and you can you can
talk all you like about how
you don't care about looks you don't
care about height you don't care about
weight you don't care about number one a
bank account i think there's like two
things here there's like
obviously no one is going to disagree
with you know someone's height does not
reflect at all on their value as a human
being someone's money does not reflect
on the value as a human being there is
like a sense of
that these are arbitrary measurements
hopefully it does not need to be stated
these arbitrary measurements correlate
with someone's actual worth as a human
being
and but that's not the market that we're
talking about we're talking about a
market which is different to that which
is the
dating marketplace which is very sort of
a specific interesting use case where
as much as you would like for there to
be no different as much as i would love
to be equally attracted to women of all
insert traits here x here
in reality i'm attracted to
women who are more on a particular end
of the spectrum of whatever trait
or whatever trait we're thinking about
and there's very little i can actually
do to change that
um
whereas obviously if women are
on one end of a spectrum of trait x
compared to another end i'm not valuing
them any more or less as a human being
yeah so that's that's one of the
problems that we've had is that
preferences have been conflated with
some sort of value judgment about
people's worth and that's not the case
but you can't deny the fact that if you
prefer
something to something else that's
simply your biology bearing it out now
we can
we can have some sort of uh
judgments around our
around our preferences but the vast
majority of this is limbic as hell like
it's just some bit of the brain yeah
back here you're not consciously
choosing the things that you're
attracted to
if you're a girl and you like black guys
like did you choose the fact that you
like black guys or do you just tend to
like the
construct the way that those people look
do you tend to like artists or musicians
or whatever it might be who chose that
did you choose it or did something else
choose it from you and you're right it's
where preferences
really get borne out so you see the same
thing
in the marketplace there's two things
that you can't really defeat one of them
is desire and the other one's money so
people can virtue signal all they want
but there's been to bring it back to the
love island example there has been
criticisms around lack of diversity in
terms of
sexual expression in terms of race in
terms of a bunch of other things um
if is it itv's job
to make a show which is diverse or is it
itv's job to make a show which is
successful
because the market will reward the one
which is successful so people should
vote with their feet or their eyes
if they want to change something in the
market if you don't want love island to
be the way that it is then stop watching
it and decide to try and campaign to get
something else or make something
yourself the same thing goes for in the
dating market like
desire will always win out the person
that will be campaigning for why gender
is a social construct and why masculine
traits are completely arbitrary and
look at the person that that person is
dating and they will almost definitely
have some of the predictable traits that
someone is looking for in a partner
again
it's i don't understand why it's
controversial to bring up the fact that
people have preferences and those
preferences are not just ones that we've
chosen the ones that have been embedded
in us for quite a while
it makes sense that men want women that
are fertile because that's what we're
here for we're here to survive and
reproduce it makes sense that women want
men who can get access to resources
status gave you access to resources
money is a proxy for resources education
is a
predictor of future ability to attain
resources
why would this be a surprise but
the last few years has uh kind of turned
things upside down a little bit like
this so we've talked a lot about and i i
think we're having these sorts of
discussions uh this is the stuff that my
brother and i often talk about on a
podcast as well and
we find that when we get emails about it
afterwards from people who are upset
with the way a certain thing was
discussed there's
one thing
one thing which they point out very very
recently actually and i and i agree with
this is that there's a difference
between talking in broad general
generalities about averages
and how those averages bear out for a
specific individual and then a step
further
how the knowledge of the averages should
dictate the behavior of
an individual
and so what i mean by that is um
so to to use a personal example
women are on average attracted to men
that display more alpha male tendencies
it's probably not a particularly
controversial point like you know traits
like assertiveness assertiveness
confidence aggression
bordering on aggression
those sorts of kind of things that you
would expect if you see if you if you
think alpha male for example
on average women are attracted to those
and there's very little they can
actually do about it i actually recently
read um
my secret garden by nancy someone which
is like a book that was released a few
decades ago the first time women's
sexual fantasies was published in
writing and
apparently that book had like i was
doing a bunch of research on this took
the world by storm and became an instant
best seller because people were like oh
my god like
this is what women's sexual fantasies
are and all the women were like oh my
god i didn't realize other people were
like this too wow and a lot of them the
vast majority are around um
the
thing things that you know
um you know things that uh display
overly alpha male tendencies on a man's
part um it's not to say women want these
things to bear out in real life but
on average we can like let's assume
women are more attracted to those sorts
of traits
then when it comes like okay cool that's
fine and that's a that's a an academic
point based on maybe uh average maybe 51
of women are more attracted to that say
but there's still a vast
proportion of women who are not
and so for someone like me reading about
this stuff i think
the danger is then i can start to think
that okay if women are more attracted to
alpha male traits
and that is not really the sort of
person who i am because of various
reasons the way that i maybe some nature
maybe some nurture the way that i was
raised is a very sort of feminized kind
of culture where alpha male traits are
sort of considered to be downtrodden and
this is this is like not a good way to
be
but given that i'm not particularly
having success in the dating marketplace
um then
should i try to adopt such as these
alpha male traits and should i mold my
personality in a way that makes me more
attractive to women because you know
i'm gonna find a wife you know for the
first half for the first x number of
years of my life there was a good quote
from someone who said that um life is
always in two stages the first stage is
only trying to find a partner and the
second stage is when you actually take
once you've done that you realize okay
who the hell am i and what do i do
and so given that i'm competing in this
dating marketplace should i try and get
that master's degree should i try and be
more domineering be more confident be
more aggressive should i try and go to
the gym and get more hench because you
know
should i put a topless picture on tindo
that shows me smiling without my teeth
because that's considered
higher i don't know so this is
this is one of the problems like
generally with dating and i appreciate
you know all of the people that
send in their thoughts
my mind isn't fixed on these things
right like i just have a real
perverse
curiosity around all of the things to do
with the dating market and i hope that
that comes across in good faith because
that's genuinely how it is there's two
things going on one of them is how much
how much can you play the game without
compromising who you are truthfully yep
um and the other one is how far do you
go before you
basically play persona which is what we
spent the first half of this
conversation talking about right you
don't want to you don't want to make
someone fall in love with a version of
you that you're not but also like
maximizing your attractiveness
understanding the rules of the game
like
you can't pick the ball up in football
but you can run faster with it you
understand that if there's a good tactic
that means you can score a bit more if
you have this particular set piece
that's not too bad yeah what happened
and the problem with pickup artistry and
this is
something that i really really
got icked by
the whole negging and and you've got it
if people don't know what pickup
artistry is it was sort of during the
early 2000s and the mid-2010s where men
had found particular neuro-linguistic
programming tricks that allowed them to
bed women by um utilizing different
cognitive biases basically it's kind of
like tricking where it was
psychologically tricking women into bed
or tricking women into being attracted
by them and that's kind of been really
thrown out of the window
that being said there are certain rules
and procedures that will make you more
attractive to a woman the first thing i
would do is go to the gym like it is
the most robust
way
to make it's more attractive than having
a beard or having a low voice which are
two other signs of high testosterone so
this is rob henderson's work looked at
this that it's the most robust way to
become more attractive as a guy is to be
in good shape this doesn't mean single
digit body fat at 220 pounds this just
means like you know
slightly visible abs and probably
a medium-sized t-shirt or above that is
you are
top
probably five percent
of physiques on the planet if you if
you're able to get yourself to sub 14
body fat with a little bit of
vascularity on you on your arms like and
that's not oh
so it's a difficult question man like
how far are you supposed to push
yourself in the effort to become
attractive to the opposite sex it's a
really difficult question you don't want
to make someone fall in love with you
for something that you're not and this
is for guys and girls
so a good question to ask yourself is
am i the sort of person
that the sort of person i'm attracted to
would be attracted to
yeah what's the sort of person i want to
get if i really really really love guys
that go to the gym but i'm a chick that
has never been to the gym
you gotta go to the gym because he's
probably gonna want a partner that goes
to the gym as well if you're a dude who
really loves music and really wants a
partner that's into music you need to
start going out to gigs and trying to
find girls that are there stop looking
for them in the library so
models by mark manson have you read this
yeah phenomenal so that's as far as i'm
concerned it's the one-stop shop for men
on dating um how to become a more
confident human
yes you should take the knowledge that
you know around the dating market as men
and as women and you should utilize it
to inform the way that you try and date
but there has to be a point at which you
go okay
i can't compromise myself too much and a
final piece of framing that actually i
did take from
um pickup artistry but that is as
ethical as you can get is to control the
frame so you are the prize in the
interaction this doesn't mean that you
don't think that the other person's
important or interesting or valuable but
entering a frame of a conversation
saying
i am
an inherently valuable interesting
person this person is fortunate to be
going out for a walking date with me and
to grab a coffee like how cool like i'm
gonna get to find out about them and
they're gonna get to find out about me
if i was them i would be about to have a
really cool afternoon like that is a
great way to enter a frame i think for
dating high value you're controlling the
context you're coming across confident
and competent like those are good ways
to step into things
certainly better than like oh i'll start
speaking to a friend and then i won't
look at her and then when i do look at
her i'll tell her that her hair looked
[ __ ] and like that was that was never
going to be a sustainable
strategy i like this way of approaching
things like um
understand the rules of the game and use
those rules of the game to inform to
maybe inform what you're going to do to
maximize your chances in the game um
but don't
do it in a way that
feels to you inauthentic to who you
truly are
that makes a lot of sense um
ah and on the on that note we did have a
a comment on one of the one of the
videos that i did with with my brother
where i was like oh these guys are
acting as if finding love is a game it's
like okay no it's just a metaphor
just like life is a game anyway um
but
uh yeah i think i said so
the
the kind of one specific example that i
i often think about
um a few a few months ago i was i was on
a date and afterwards we went out
driving what's a typical ali abdul day
give me give me the
like quintessential ali is taking you
out for a date where does he take you
and what does he do
um
i feel like a date in three parts is
ideal where kind of you know the whole
again from the from the world of pick
apartheid where i think this is actually
a good a good shout uh bouncing from one
location to another so starting off with
maybe grabbing a coffee then going for a
walk and then you're going for the walk
had a bit of a chat then go for food
somewhere and then after the food
somewhere like a third part maybe go for
a drive or go for another walk or go for
dessert or you know just something that
allegedly the way
the way the dating thing works like if
you've if you've been sitting
sitting at dinner talking for three
hours that's psychologically a less um
it feels like you're less close than if
you've been talking for one hour at
three different venues which is just how
we experience memories um but one thing
i like to do is go for a drive
afterwards especially if it's a place
i've driven to and in the tesla in the
tesla of course
with the heated seats uh and we were
driving to the mcdonald's drive-through
which is again one of my favorite spots
because i like i love i love mcdonald's
drive-throughs and
i think weirdly
going on a mcdonald's drive-through on a
date is like very me and if someone
doesn't like that then great that's like
a perfect filter i like that um it's a
stress test it's a stress test quite
yeah but then
on on one of these dates a few months
ago on route to the mcdonald's
drive-thru um we put some music on and
uh played driver's license by olivia
rodrigo
bang a song basically or let's
imagine like a disney song okay
that kind of vibe okay and i knew all
the lyrics to actually driver's license
and good for you by olivia rodriguez
i knew all the lyrics of the disney song
and i was thinking to at that point i
could make a choice do i be myself and
sing along to this disney song
um or do i
recognize that oh girls are more
attracted to masculine traits this me
love freaking loving olivia rodrigo and
disney songs and knowing all the words
are good for you is not a particularly
masculine trait at least by traditional
definitions maybe
it's only date number two maybe i'll
just like turn that down a bit and and
weave it in and i made the decision at
that point to be like screw it let's
sing the songs and turns out she also
freaking loves singing disney songs in
olivia rodrigo and we're just singing
along together and it was great but i
was kind of thinking that
have i
in a sense shot myself in the foot by
revealing this aspect to me and then
afterwards i was like nah it's fine like
this is who i am authentically this is
this is my true self it's all good yes
if it turns out the girl is not into
guys who like sing singing disney songs
she's not gonna enjoy being with me
because i sing disney songs all the time
all day every day um
but the fact that i had that thought
process made me wonder oh have i drunk
too much kool-aid of like red that's a
dude
that's a really really good a really
really good insight that
you get a um
it's the midwife meme man
it's a midwife mean it's like the idiot
and the genius do the same thing
just
i just be myself i just be myself i will
optimize my red pill pick up artistry so
that i understand the negging of the
blah blah like no no just be yourself
but you are right like understanding the
dynamics i think is different to making
letting them change you um
i think that you did the right thing i
think that just being yourself with
somebody is a really good way to to try
and do that now if yourself is becoming
a more competent more trustworthy more
hardworking
more attractive human over time
that's a win
but trying to this is one of the reasons
why all of the pickup artists guys if
you look at them now they're all wrecked
like look at uh neil strauss who's gone
total awakened like
dmt guy
why tucker max took her max is a perfect
example man the guy did
what he wrote he created the frat eye
genre didn't he oh did he oh
all of his new york times bestsellers
were him
throwing up in bathrooms after drinking
and having sex with women oh that's all
he did i just know him from being
what women want with geoffrey miller the
evolutionary psychologist right oh dude
his entire back catalogue of books is
just him having sex and partying that's
all it is he's got a lot of reading yeah
precisely um
and he's done
a thousand sessions of psychotherapy
mdma assisted psychotherapy now this
like fully awakened human talking on
twitter about real me deep and
meaningful things why
i think it's because when
guys
in their youth
and they in their 20s
tried to be the sort of man that they
thought women wanted to be attracted to
they ended up realizing how far that was
from the person that they truly were and
it made them feel really really unhappy
and uncomfortable and they relapsed
after a lot of self-work to a much more
virtuous much more aligned and awakened
place which is them just fully being
themselves neil strauss now incredibly
vulnerable online tucker max incredibly
vulnerable online why because for a long
time he wasn't for a long time he was
doing the things that he thought he was
supposed to do
and i think that you've played it right
i think that the way to go about things
is to have confident competence that
this is you and own it and be like look
yeah maybe this isn't whatever typical
masculine trait 101 the red pill guys
say that you shouldn't do this it's all
right but
also if you want to try and be your
version of someone else the best that
you can hope for is being the second
best in the world at it like if i want
to do my podcast like joe rogan the best
i can hope for is being the second best
joe rogan on the planet
and when you're going into a dating
environment
i just setting the tone in that way is
going to be bad that being said if you
have more extreme quirks
if it was
i can't think of any pg-13 but if you
had something that was a little bit more
out there than
you singing disney songs perhaps you do
slowly introduce
people to that but the prospect of never
bringing that up i don't think that
really works interesting so i guess if i
had a strong
if for example it was just part of my
part of the way i live life that i never
have a shower and i don't believe in
washing that's uh
you know i think that a future partner
would want to know but it's probably the
sort of thing i should mention on date
number one let's just do it
well i think that
what you would be aiming to do and what
everyone's aiming to do is to try and
construct a world in which they are the
sort of person that the sort of person
they're attracted to would be attracted
to that's what you want this is
this is the the sort of quick fix to
dating problems it's like okay what what
sort of partner do i want genuinely what
are their interests what are the
non-negotiables that i want from a
partner they have to and choose three
things non-negotiables they have to be
like this
they have to be
pick them
and then all of the other things you can
just kind of learn to love people around
them that doesn't mean that you need to
settle but it does mean i think you end
up in a situation where you have the
things that really matter
being there and then you're starting to
love people for their quirks like a lot
of the times when you fall in love you
end up falling in love and going i can't
believe it was you
it was never going to be you you you
with all of your eunice and all of the
different things that you have how is it
you it was supposed to be her but it's
you
and you can't believe it why because you
are absolutely [ __ ] at predicting what
you're going to be attracted to you know
some things that you will not compromise
on and then the rest of them you end up
falling in love with the way that he
drives the car or you end up falling in
love with the way that she
uh
makes the bed or the way that she looks
on him like all of the things that you
wouldn't have thought it was going to be
like this is where love seems to come
out and it's those quirks and those
uniquenesses that
give you a competitive advantage in the
dating market so you not utilizing the
fact that you do sing disney songs and
you do know that the words to them
that puts you at a disadvantage because
you're just being like
ali norp version 0.9 you're the beta
tester version of that because it's
you're not fully utilizing all of the
different features you have
yeah i think i guess i guess it is that
everyone has to make that decision for
themselves what is the balance between
i am doing this thing to become more
attractive versus uh and and not it and
it not bordering into territory of this
thing is straying
far from who i am for example i'll hold
my hands up and say the reason i go to
the gym is to be more attractive
um but the sort of person i want to be
is the sort of person who takes the
health seriously yeah and it just so
happens that the proximal reason like
the main reason is currently to look
more attractive but it's also a sort of
life that i would like to lead and
therefore i think
dude if you can win on multiple if you
can win on multiple different domains
like take it take it it's like saying um
my youtube channel gets plays which
means that i have access to making new
friends but it also earns ad revenue but
i should feel bad about the ad revenue
because i'm supposed to be here for the
friends it's like no like just take them
all if there's a ton of wins to get out
of something but to come back to what we
said at the for the first half of the
conversation about being yourself and
about trying to kind of work out who it
is that you are
i think that
coming out something from place of i'm
already enough but i want to be better
is very different to i am insufficient
unless i have this unless i get eight
body fat and massive set of arms and i
can out bench everybody in the gym
unless i get there then i am not worthy
of having a partner is very different to
i am already worthy of having a partner
and i know that this will make them
happier like and or this will improve my
chances of finding someone who is going
to be attracted to me and i'm going to
be attracted to as well how do you think
about the balance between be yourself
versus choose yourself
elaborate
so so we've talked a lot about how
you're
you know you went on this journey trying
to uncover your true self
um
one school of thought is that well we
don't really have a true self that true
self is just a result of the accidents
of our um the accidents of the way that
we were brought up and it just and the
traits we got from our parents and from
our friends at school
and
you can
do a lot to change who you are if that's
what you want
want to do for example when i was in
school i wasn't particularly outgoing or
particularly charismatic or particularly
confident and i recognized that
you know
me being myself would have been me just
continuing on that route i decided you
know what i'm going to make an active
decision at university to change myself
to become someone who's more confident
and more charismatic
and someone who is a little bit more
outgoing and although that was not a
natural transformation initially it felt
it felt uncomfortable like any change
which always feels feels uncomfortable i
am now much more confident charismatic
open in social settings that kind of
stuff
but if i'd been told um oh bro just be
yourself it would have probably that
probably wouldn't have happened and so
i'm curious as to what what your
thoughts are on that so
i believe that your life should be lived
by design not by default
that you should be intentionally doing
things because the default quite often
is actually a bit [ __ ]
the the default setting that you would
go to would be the netflix and bag of
chips and
not doing hard things and not having new
experiences and all of the biases or you
would just be ruled by your biases right
which is definitely not what you want
that being said
we are not infinitely malleable we are
not complete blank slates there are
predispositions that you have that i do
not and there are predispositions i have
that you do not
50 pretty much of everything you are
psychologically is genetic
on average
[Laughter]
and what that means is that you are
inclined towards certain things more
than others
by hooker by crook you haven't ended up
being an artist
or a
painter or a
club promoter or a reality tv guy yeah
like there is something inside of you
that has caused you to lean toward the
particular life that you do now
understanding yourself and saying right
i'm going to
play to my strengths i'm going to
enhance so one of your strengths is
being able to learn things quickly right
so
you have a meta power that permits you
to be more malleable than most people
but it's not unlimited you can't learn
to be anything that you want you can
just learn to be
you can manipulate certain areas of you
to enhance some and to down regulate
others
the difference between
be yourself and choose yourself is
interesting
but especially as you grow up
your
life paths they do start to get closed
off more right because you have less and
less time presumably most people will
want to start a family of some kind
which again is something that you're
working toward as you grow up
and
yeah it's an interesting one i think um
i think that choosing yourself has
a beauty to it and a sense of
achievement once you've completed it
i think that's really really nice and
you can feel proud of the person that
you are
but that needs to come from a place of
inner truth or else you're just going to
end up playing a role you're not going
to be so if you decided tomorrow that
you wanted to wake up and be a pt in a
gym and just be some super alpha go out
sniff a bag with the boys on a weekend
like five pints and watch the footy or
did you see the west ham game last night
mate like if you decided to be that guy
i'm sure that you could probably fl but
you absolutely could force yourself into
it if someone held a gun to your head
and said right you've got to be the
biggest lad that you can for the next
year you could do it but it wouldn't be
you
so you can't fully choose yourself you
could
act
yourself but the difference between
choose and be is basically does this
feel like it's
cohesive with my inner desire and what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
remove the distance from what you would
do and what you want to do so what would
i do if i woke up this morning i would
maybe
do some meditation and do some walking
it's can i get something from system two
to system one and the more that you get
the things that you want in system two
to system one that's you creating
yourself to be yourself does that make
sense
like if you can choose the things that
you want to have in life and you can
make them so much a part of you that
they actually end up embodying you and
you embody them that feels like that
feels like you've managed to merge the
two together yeah it's sort of like
habit formation but for personality
traits i guess yeah and also for the
values that you have yeah for me i was a
guy that took a lot of pride from the
success of his club night and from the
way that he was seen and blah blah blah
don't get me wrong i've probably just
transmuted them into other different
like desires and once and
[ __ ] um but i got rid of those ones
because i didn't want them anymore so i
guess you can choose yourself but you're
not infinitely malleable
amazing i think that's a a good place to
end this uh we still have so much to
talk about about your podcast about your
journey about your uh the whole
weirdness stuff authenticity wanting to
want things i think we'll save that for
a part two because this is officially
the longest episode we've ever recorded
on the deep belt um i have a few uh
rapid fire questions for you hit me two
end widths that we're asking everyone um
what advice number one what advice would
you give to your younger self
fear less
fear less fear less
who has had the biggest influence on
your career dave my older business
partner a guy that is the ceo of the
company that we're twinned with okay
what was the influence that he had he
was the first boss i ever had he was the
first role model i ever had he's about
four or five years older than me and he
is
just a very very shrewd
guy when it comes to business almost all
of the business acumen that i have can
be attributed the genesis of it can be
attributed to that guy nice what's one
tip for someone looking for success
sleep more
what does the first and last hour of
your day look like
upon waking
element salt in water
walk for 15 minutes
journal
meditate
breath work
read
cook and then on a night time
usually
watching
some sport or whatever with my
flatmate in the
living room or re and then some sort of
reading probably half and half nice i
need to ask you more about your morning
routine next time we speak um
what material item under a hundred
pounds could you not live without slash
that's added the most value to your life
in recent memory under 100 pounds
steel shaker
oh just steal protein shaker about 15
quid cool
what book would you recommend to anyone
the almanac of naval ravikant nice if
you lost everything how would you start
the business again fill a club night
easy
what quote or mantra do you live by
don't practice what you do not want to
become
nice
um and finally a journey or destination
journey
very nice chris thanks for coming on
links to all of your things in the video
description uh anything in particular
you'd like to plug uh yet those episodes
that we mentioned will be linked in the
show notes below modern wisdom wherever
you listen apple podcast spotify youtube
chris williamson and if you want a list
of 100 books we've talked about a lot
today uh
chriswilex.com books is a free list of
100 of the most impactful and
interesting books that i've ever read
thanks for having me on and we'll link
uh my appearances on your podcast as
well in addition which is awesome oh
thank you
great thanks for coming on and see you
later everyone